la roumanie s'apprête à passer son
premier réveillon de liberté le nouveau
régime de bucarest prépare les élections
d'avril prochain
la démocratie avance pas à pas
gigantesque chaîne de la paix à
jérusalem plusieurs milliers de
manifestants pacifistes autour de la
vieille ville
un défilé qui s'est terminée par des
heurts avec la police israël y ait un
conflit lointain et oublier la corée un
seul peuple vivant dans deux pays
différents
5 millions de familles séparées depuis
40 ans en france les petits pompistes en
voie de disparition des mesures
d'urgence prises pour que les stations
service ne disparaissent pas des routes
françaises bonsoir la roumanie se
prépare donc à finir l'année 89 dans la
liberté une liberté chèrement acquise
on le sait 1990 sera pour les romains
l'année des premières élections libres
depuis bien longtemps
comment les habitants de bucarest près
par ce premier réveillon de l'après
ceausescu
c'est ce que nous allons savoir
immédiatement retrouvant en direct sur
place la nouzonville spéciaux stéphane
magnier stéphane quelle est l'ambiance
on écoute et l'ambiance est celle que
l'on peut imaginer c'est à dire des gens
qui ont fait beaucoup de courses qui
n'ont pas pu en faire pour noël puisque
ont tiré dans la rue alors évidemment
les magasins étaient parfaitement
inaccessible mais aujourd'hui ce sont un
petit peu rattraper d'autant plus qu'en
roumanie le grand réveillant celui ont
fait la fête toute la nuit c'est celui
du 31 décembre donc tout le monde se
prépare se prépare à encore demain
d'ailleurs exceptionnellement les
magasins sont ouverts
et puis vous ne voyez pas grand monde
dans les rues tout simplement parce
qu'il y à une heure de décalage horaire
et donc neuf heures du soir ici en
roumanie
et c'est dire si tout le monde bien
entendu surtout avec une telle neige est
rentré chez soi
stéphane ici à paris on attend des
nouvelles des petits roumains qui ont
été adoptés par plusieurs familles
françaises
avez vous des nouvelles fraîches
oui nous avons des nouvelles toutes
fraîches qui nous avons eu la
possibilité n'oserait même pas dire la
chance en tout cas nous avons eu la
possibilité d'aller les voir cet après
midi ce sont les enfants qui sont donc
déjà à moitié français qu'ils ne
connaissent pas encore cette ce pays qui
vont espérons le voir d'ici une
quinzaine de jours ils sont dans un
orphelinat nous n'avons pas tout vu nous
en avons vu une quarantaine
bruno gex et jean-françois hoffman ont
fait la visite de leurs chambres de leur
territoire pour l'instant gaul à deux
jours quelles pertes robert sillonnent
les rues enneigées de plus car est
médecin du monde lui a confié une
mission délicate recueillir le maximum
d'informations sur l'état de santé de 85
enfants est mort dont les familles
adoptives sûr sans nouvelles depuis plus
de deux ans ils sont une vingtaine ici à
la crèche sainte catherine le plus grand
orphelinat du sud est européen
ce que je souhaitais qu'ils contenaient
des images et ces enfants que moi j'ai
vu hier en très bonne santé en très bon
état pour qu'on puisse y soir le montre
en france à la télévision et que les
parents voient que leurs enfants vont
bien comme à l'heure de la sieste c'est
christine à mon réveil la première
christina florissant cette petite fille
de trois ans et lui qui n'a pas voulu
hébrard en français depuis 1987
elle est très jolie
nous n'avons pas la garde la corde et
les étages c'était des irritations des
yeux des autorités pour permettre à ses
bas ses parents visitaient le 100 francs
et pour quelles raisons vous n'aviez pas
cet accord sa jeunesse à pas et je crois
que toutes les procédures d'adoption
avaient été débloqués jusque là pas
recherché ce coup lui même en quête de
reconnaissance internationale il
exigeait du gouvernement français
d'intervenir officiellement un chantage
toujours refusée par paris
ceux ci ont perdu l'habitude des visites
à notre arrivée le bras se tendent
la joie de ces enfants avides de chaleur
humaine likouala maca rescousse trois
ans et demi j'ai parents avec le sud de
la france
ils attendent entre six mois et un an
luisi les a vus souvent et s'est
beaucoup investie comme ses parents
vis-à-vis de lui ce sont les mais sans
appel pas mais c'est dans ta tête dans
le drame est lancé dans toute sa
sensibilité et maintenant il va
retourner vers cette image très positive
et ça doit être aussi accusé le problème
de sa fragilité
mais je partirai beaucoup de murs et
vous puissiez donner de l'information
passe pas très bien
bientôt nicolas et ses petits camarades
rejoindront leurs parents en france
d'ici quelques semaines le nouveau
gouvernement roumain
on a fait la promesse
je voudrais vous dire encore que il y à
ici à quelques dizaines de mètres de moi
deux paires de pères qui sont venus dès
le début des événements pour essayer de
voir leurs enfants et de les ramener
avec eux et qui pour l'instant attendent
qui quand pratiquement jour et nuit à
l'ambassade
en espérant que ils vont pouvoir emmener
leurs enfants avec eux d'ici quelques
jours pour l'instant ils attendent comme
tous les autres ses enfants qui vont
passer vraisemblablement espérons le
leur dernier réveillon de fin d'année
ici en roumanie et que 1990 sera le
début pour en tout cas d'une nouvelle
vie merci stéphane nous avons reçu ici à
paris les premières images de ce qui
s'est passé le 17 décembre dernier à
timisoara la ville où a commencé le
soulèvement ou la ville qui apparemment
payé le plus lourd tribut à la
révolution que ces images tournées par
un amateur montre l'arrivée sur des
chardons team usa aura des charges qui
ensuite est ouvert le feu sur la foule
amy crise de panique m des images
d'amateurs quand je vous laisse
découvrir quelques secondes voici les
chars qui entrent dans la ville de
timisoara images ont été diffusées
aujourd'hui par la télévision yougoslave
la tchécoslovaquie elle savoure les
joies de la liberté retrouvée sans
violence sont morts après l'élection de
vastes laval hier à la présidence du
pays
prague a fait la fête toute la nuit
christophe tortora la tchécoslovaquie
s'est offert une saint sylvestre avec
deux jours d'avancé en dépit du froid
mordant plusieurs milliers de personnes
sont descendues hier dans les rues de
prague fêter l'élection de vaclav havel
à la présidence de la république
tchécoslovaque
drago et touristes ont dansé sur des
musiques traditionnelles au pied de la
statue du héros de fragments ux 1
le dramaturge est venu saluer brièvement
la foule massée sur la place de la
vieille ville et le président portugais
mario soares avait tenu être l'un des
premiers à féliciter celui qui fut le
plus illustre des dissidents sous
l'ancien régime communiste
pour clore momentanément ce chapitre de
l'actualité à l'est deux sondages
concordants réalisé en france et en
grande-bretagne
michael gorbatchev fait visiblement
l'unanimité il a été élu homme de
l'année selon une étude d'opinion de la
sofres publiée aujourd'hui par le figaro
le deuxième sondage a été réalisé auprès
des téléspectateurs britanniques qui ont
eu désigner le numéro un du kremlin
hommes d'états de la décennie en israël
la chaîne de la paix organisée par des
pacifistes a été brisée par des heurts
violents avec la police
cette manifestation géante autour des
murailles de la vieille ville de
jérusalem s'est en effet terminée par
des affrontements entre manifestants
palestiniens et forces de l'ordre israël
il ya des erreurs qui ont fait plusieurs
dizaines de blessés sur place pour
antenne 2 charles enderlin
ce devait être la fête de la paix un
gigantesque happening pacifique autour
de la vieille ville de jérusalem
israéliens et palestiniens côte à côte
en compagnie de 1300 personnalités venus
d'europe et des états unis
quinze mille personnes selon la police
plus de 20 mille selon les organisateurs
devant la forte de hérode les policiers
affirment avoir entendu des slogans olp
interdite et subitement sans le moindre
avertissement ils ont lancé des grenades
lacrymogènes dans la foule
le premier blessé
la police tire débit et des balles en
caoutchouc sur des manifestants deux
neveux n'ai aucune provocation
un médecin israélien soigne un
palestinien
les secouristes palestiniens ont été
touchés par des balles en caoutchouc
un peu plus loin la manifestation s'est
reconstitué par bill de pop et il ya une
grande majorité pour la paix et c'est
incidents créés mais cette attaque
criminelle de la police ne changera rien
toutes les guerres j'ai participé juste
participer je suis capitaine de chars je
donnais pour tout légaliserait l'asie
c'est comme tout le monde j'ai reçu du
gage et c'est tout la seule raison que
je vais la paix nous en avons marre
jusqu'à la nous voulons une paix vite et
vite porte de damas cent mètres plus
loin la police disperse les derniers
attroupement il ya une cinquantaine de
blessés dont plusieurs français
légèrement atteint 45 arrestations des
israéliens des palestiniens et des
étrangers pour qui une journée de
fraternité à sion s'est terminé derrière
les barreaux
ces événements ont scandale en israël
situation toujours confuse au panama les
états unis et le vatican continue de
négocier sur le sort du général noriega
l'ancien dictateur réfugié à l'ambassade
du vatican à panama city
plus d'une semaine après le début de
leurs opérations militaires les troupes
américaines semble s'embourber dans le
conflit pas la mer incident diplomatique
très significatif hier des militaires
américains ont fait irruption dans
l'ambassade du nicaragua panama
explications chaque violer cet incident
va compliquer la situation des quelques
25 mille hommes de l'armée américaine au
panama
vendredi soir une soixantaine de gi's
fonte irruption dans l'ambassade du
nicaragua panama et donne l'ordre à
l'ambassadeur ainsi qu'à 7 nicaraguayen
de quitter les lieux pour pouvoir
fouiller les bâtiments une intervention
justifiée par des rumeurs faisant état
de caches d'armes dans l'ambassade
la fouille durera deux heures selon le
colonel américain porte parole du
commandement au panama des armes des
pistolets mitrailleurs et des grenades
antichar aurait été découverte
pour l'ambassadeur du nicaragua au
panama il s'agit là d'une atteinte à la
souveraineté nationale
une violation du droit et des
conventions internationales
en représailles à cette intrusion des
troupes américaines
le président du nicaragua daniel ortega
a ordonné l'expulsion de vin diplomates
américains en poste à managua
les négociations piétinent entre les
états unis et le vatican sur
l'extradition du général noriega
toujours réfugié à la nonciature à
panama depuis le 20 décembre date de
leur arrivée au panama et trouve
américaine en certes les ambassades du
nicaragua de cuba et de la libye de
crainte que noriega puisse y trouver des
appuis tout même un refuge
et puis nous n'avons appris juste avant
ce journal l'urss vient de demander le
retrait immédiat des troupes américaines
au panama
l'ambassadeur des etats-unis à moscou a
été convoquée d'urgence
l'union soviétique parle de violation
des lois internationales jusqu'à présent
bosco avait été plutôt discrète dans
cette affaire pas la mienne
un conflit lointain et presque oublié à
présent celui de la corée l'accord est
divisée en deux depuis 40 1,5 million de
familles coréennes vivent séparées par
la ligne de démarcation entre le nord et
le sud
5 millions de familles qui espère
toujours se trouvaient réunis un jour
reportage j'ai en bonis gilbert usant
malaisien que nous pleurions tellement
ma soeur et moi que nous ne pouvions pas
parler nous nous retrouvions après 36
ans et 8 mois de séparation sans parler
aux quelque chose nous venaient
directement au coeur je me disais nous
ne sommes pas morte
nous voilà ensemble
on dit qu il y a cinq millions de
familles séparées
moi j'avais la chance d'être parmi les
50 retourner la voir
je ne vous dis pas le nombre de
personnes âgées qui viennent me voir
juste pour me serrer la main parce que
je suis allé là bas
leur voyage à eux s'est arrêtée au 38e
parallèle comme 5 millions d'autres
familles séparées ils n'ont pas la
moindre nouvelle depuis 40 ans de leurs
parents du nord pas la moindre lettre
pas le moindre coup de téléphone
ils ne savent même pas s'ils sont encore
en vie
sous ce monument portant l'inscription
leur lieu de naissance leur manque ce
rituel confucianiste s'adresse à la
famille du père de cet homme il pleurait
souvent surtout les jours de fête
il nous disait j'ai envie de les revoir
il est mort à 90 ans il avait assez vécu
il n'avait rien à regretter
sauf de n'avoir plus retourner dans son
pays kim sin femme porte un nom de
garçons comme c'est de coutume en corée
pour une troisième fille toute sa
réussite
elle l'a menée avec acharnement contre
ce double handicap de départ
être femme et venir de corée du nord
exilé sans famille au sud
sinon son mari épousé avant de fuir son
père riche propriétaire symboliser pour
les révolutionnaires de corée du nord
les valeurs à habas et mon père et moi
nous sommes passés au sud
chacun de notre côté pendant la guerre
de corée malheureusement
lui il a été arrêté et emmené par ces
gens lors il est probablement mort à
l'heure qu'il est je dois un jour
retourner dans mon pays donc je me dis
d'ici là je dois continuer à vivre coûte
que coûte
je ne dois pas mourir avant d'avoir vu
mon pays
elle a dans son malheur la chance d'être
dans quelques jours du prochain voyage
vers le nord le deuxième en 40 ans
retour en france pour une histoire peu
banale un conte de fin d'année mais en
1613 la maison mellerio est devenu à
travers les siècles une véritable
légende
comment quelques ramoneur italiens sont
ide à l'origine de ce qui est devenu la
plus ancienne entreprise française c'est
le bon point de la semaine
reportage jean-pierre métivet vers la
piste saut la plus ancienne entreprise
française on la doit dès que le noir et
à une conjuration se mêler rios dits
meller joaillier rue de la paix
l'affairé remonte à marie de médicis et
depuis elle a toujours scintiller entre
les mains d'une même famille mais tout a
débuté par un complot en 1613 ce complot
des ramoneurs vont le découvrir
chaque année ils viennent sur paris
depuis trois minuscule village d'italie
certains d'entre eux au 8 ans l'un
travaille chez m pido lui à un monopole
le ramonage des cheminées du louvre où
se trouve la cour du roi depuis les
toits du palais par un conduit l'un de
ces ramoneur l'un de ces gosses pas
surprendre un complot contre le jeune
louis xiii ci de là que vont être les
soudaine richesse de trois villages
italiens
en italie à kravets jannah laisse trop
habile estre et y la joie que mes morts
toujours l'événement avoir déjoué le
complot marie de médicis leur a accordé
un privilège extraordinaire auquel
n'avaient même pas droit les français
celui de pouvoir colporter vendre
acheter à paris ou dans tout autre lieu
du royaume les quincailleries orfèvrerie
sans être inquiétés ni troublé par les
orfèvres et les mercier locaux à
l'amérique ravages
on conserve pieusement s'était dit royal
de 1613 le plus étonnant le privilège
sera renouvelée à chaque règne par louis
xiii accédant au trône
puis par louis xiv puis par louis 15 et
enfin par louis saez en 1760
c'est l'histoire extraordinaire d'un
contrat de reconnaissance entre la
royauté française et les habitants de ce
petit village dont la famille mellerio
qui a duré pendant 200 ans
la cravache à peine 3000 habitants
pourtant l'église renferme un trésor
fabuleux les offrandes à la vierge de
tout ce qu'ils ont réussi au village
comme les mellerio devenu chevalier à
paris la piété italienne et puis des
dévotions plus matérialiste
car dans l'église on trouve aussi des
robes de marie-antoinette racheter après
sa mort sous la révolution et transformé
en chasuble de prêtres ultime action de
grâce envers la famille des bourbons les
petits pompistes france est en voie de
disparition
deux tiers des communes de l'hexagone
n'ont plus de points de vente d'essence
l'avenir des stations vous les
stations-service de taille modeste
inquiète les pouvoirs publics le
ministre du commerce vient d'ailleurs
d'annoncer une série de mesures en
faveur de ces petits détaillants qui
souffre terriblement de la concurrence
des grandes surfaces
un exemple dans le sud de la france
patrice volet jean-françois giorgetti
ont constaté qu entre aix et marseille
la panne sèche quête les automobilistes
les pompes à la campagne ne font plus
recette 18000 fermeture depuis 81
chantal sustrac et son mari n'en sont
pas là mais en deux ans leur situation
commerciale n'a cessé de se détériorer
alors il faut compenser par une présence
de tous les jours et oublier les
vacances je vais faire beaucoup d'un an
en fait quand même six heures à 21
heures tous les jours
mais quelques jours de cet outil obligé
pour pouvoir finir par rapport à pékin
merci encore une grande surface qui sont
à côté c'est chevron est ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de clients
des villages aux côtés et donc passer
encore plusieurs de vos dans la nuit ça
aurait pu beaucoup j'en surface et un
compliment c'est pour attirer la
clientèle russe eux les salles serieys
mêmes qui gagnent pas dessus ça leur est
égal en moyenne 20 centimes de
différence avec la grande surface du
coin les clients ici viennent surtout en
dépannage tôt le matin ou tard le soir
pour les attirer quelques services
boissons cas cette clé minutes
mais le rayon épicerie lui n'a tenu que
quelques mois la seule diversification
intéressante c'est souvent un atelier
mécanique depuis dix ans c'est lui qui
fait vivre la station car en plus sa
nécessaire modernisation se heurte au
choix sans appel des compagnies
pétrolières déjà le très dur et qui ont
toujours dit nous nous faisons mais
finalement on voit souvent jamais rien
venir
c'est toujours un peu l'arlésienne
j'aurais de moderniser pour faire face à
certains critères que nous sommes là que
nous pouvons encore exister mais les
mots vraiment dia nisy commun avec
lequel capitaux lois économiques
imparable les petits mangés par les gros
il est pour bientôt le temps où la panne
sèche sera interdite sur le bord des
routes départementales
le reste de l'actualité française un
gendarme tué par un chauffard en
charente ce gendarme qui participent et
un contrôle de vitesse a été
mortellement blessé par un automobiliste
refusant de s'arrêter
le chauffard a pris la fuite après avoir
traîné les gendarmes sur plusieurs
mètres
message de condoléances de proches à
mitterrand veuve des deux policiers tués
à nîmes jeudi soir deux policiers qui
avaient trouvé la mort au cours d'une
fusillade avec un évadé de la prison de
mende
un évadé qui avait été lui-même a battu
ensuite par un autre policier
tremblement de terre ce matin
yougoslavie trois secousses se sont
produites dans une région où se trouve
la seule centrale nucléaire du pays
ce séisme n'a pas fait de dégâts mais il
intervient deux jours après le
tremblement de terre en australie deux
mois après la catastrophe de san
francisco et un an après le terrible
séisme d'armide cette semaine même la
france a été touché par une secousse
tellurique les habitants de la côte
d'azur ont eu peur mardi dernier après
un léger séisme dans leur région est ce
à dire que la terre bouge de plus en
plus non répondent les spécialistes
l'activité terrestre est normal
explications patrice pollet
le dernier tremblement de terre
important c'était en australie il ya
quelques jours une secousse de 5 degrés
5 sur l'échelle de richter selon un
sismologue australien une puissance
comparable à l'explosion de plus de 50
mille tonnes de tnt
et puis hier cette dépêche nous
apprenait que la terre tremblait à
nouveau en californie
les scientifiques américains
s'inquiètent ils redoutent un nouveau
tremblement de terre important
en fait cette menace sur la californie
pourrait s'appliquer à bien d'autres
parties sensibles de notre globe car la
terre formé il ya environ quatre
milliards d'années à un sous sol en
perpétuel mouvement sans cesse les
plaques qui forment les continents se
frottent d'entre elles se rapprochent ou
bien ses cartes
l'ondé de choc de ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler un séisme peut alors se
propager à des dizaines de kilomètres et
si une ville se trouve sur son passage
c'est la catastrophe les grands séismes
eux font parler d'eux les petites
secousses moins et pourtant elles font
partie de notre environnement quotidien
on en compte environ dix mille par an
près de 28 par jour et d'ailleurs ce
matin
la terre a tremblé par trois fois en
la vie de petites secousses certes mais
elles ont fait peur l'épicentre du
séisme se situait tout près de l'unique
centrale nucléaire yougoslave
ce n'est pas demain que les tremblements
de terre cesseront la formation de la
terre n'est pas tout à fait terminé il
nous faudra encore attendre quelques
millions d'années
un petit peu de patience en sport à
présent mais plus précisément en basket
l'équipe de france a ramassé deux juges
dans le tournoi de noël qui vient de se
terminer à bercy la france finit à la
quatrième et dernière place de cette
compétition remportée il ya quelques
minutes par l'équipe américaine des
all-stars olivier rey
deux bûches pour l'équipe de france au
tournoi de noël battus vendredi sans
gloire par une sélection de joueurs
américains
elle a subi une deuxième défaite face au
brésil
malgré l adresse exceptionnelle de
richard dacoury auteur de 35 points
l'équipe de france a une fois encore
déçu elle n'est jamais entré dans le
match
menés à la mi temps de six points malgré
les conseils de leur entraîneur francis
jordane les français n'ont jamais pu
revenir à la hauteur des brésiliens
dominés au rebond
manquant d'agressivité les français se
sont donc inclinés logiquement devant
les brésiliens sang neuf à 100 il
termine bon dernier de ce tournoi de
noël et clottes l'heure surtout l'année
1989 sur une bien mauvaise note
les résultats du tiercé quarté + qui se
courait aujourd'hui à vincennes pour le
tiercé il fallait jouer le 6 le 10 et le
deux rapports pour safran 3068 francs
dans un an différentes 216 francs 50
pour le quarté + il fallait ajouter la
ce rapport pour six françaises 1240 de
francs dans un ordre différent 660
francs
nous sommes presque à la fin de ce
journal aux alentours de minuit vous
avez rendez vous avec philippe gassot
pour la dernière édition juste après
l'émission d'antoine de caunes consacrée
au rock des années 80 ce sera à 22h40
et puis avant de vous quitter je vous
signale que l'opéra de paris donnera
demain à 14 heures une représentation
exceptionnelle de la belle au bois
dormant sur une chorégraphie de rudolf
noureev toutes les recettes de son
spectacle de ce spectacle ainsi que les
cachets des artistes seront
intégralement versés aux organismes
humanitaires qui en ce moment tente
d'aider la roumanie voilà je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée sur antenne 2
avec champs elysées dans quelques
instants juste après les prévisions
météo de josé plan la pierre je vous
donne rendez vous demain 13h bonsoir
à